we've shaped a bipartisan agreement on
the largest rescue package in American
history which was sealed last night
after a few minutes after 1:00 in the
morning when leader McConnell and I came
to the floor to announce we had an
agreement it was not a moment of
celebration but rather one of necessity
there's a Senate Minority Chuck Schumer
bit earlier saying help was on the way
for Americans after the chamber
apparently reached a deal on this
massive aid package and it is massive
this is stocks are back in the green for
the second day a day after the Dow had
his largest ever single point gained
ever could be up 15 percentage points in
two days
White House that got a mic advisor Larry
Cutler with me now Larry nice to see you
and thank you for coming back here good
afternoon to you understand there's a
glitch in the language I don't know can
it be worked out or not at the moment
Republicans say they've got an issue
with it it'll be worked out
it'll be worked out if it's what I think
it is you're referring to what
unemployment compensation yes yeah it
will be the incentive to lay off workers
apparently there's a correction the
language that's needed Larry for our
viewers here's what's in it 500 billion
dollars and assistant for corporations
fifteen and a half billion in food
stamps 130 billion for hospitals 150
billion for local governments 46 billion
for the airlines where do you start well
the total package is two trillion
dollars of direct assistance and on top
of that we are giving the Federal
Reserve the resources to put up as much
as four trillion dollars to stabilize
financial markets and back up loan
guarantees and help some distressed
industries this is all that short-term
basis because this is going to be weeks
and months not years so when you add the
two together you're looking at six
trillion dollar package bill that's
roughly 30 percent 31 percent of GDP it
is the largest Main Street financial
assistance plan in the history of the
United States let me stop you right
there
that's um I've been listening to you for
a long time Larry
just think about which is what what you
just said there Larry what will this do
to keep the greatest economy in the
world afloat well look the assistance
goes to individuals families we're
trying to keep people off of
unemployment so the small business
assistant is contingent on holding
payroll steady but you know you can't
have a job without a good business so on
that point we're guaranteeing loans to
these small businesses taking up their
expenses lost revenues we're going to
try to make up for that there is a you
know very challenging economic story
right in front of us which is beginning
now individuals look there's five
hundred billion dollars of assistance
direct checks as well as unemployment
compensation which really equals wages
in some states that may be above I think
that's what the little glitch is about
so this is a widespread package we're
trying to do the best we can to cushion
the economic consequences of the virus
that's really what we're trying it
what's the chance we come back in a
couple months and say you put what in
that bill well look I'm not sure quite
what you mean on that but I think well I
know you and fellow Republicans that you
were banging on the Obama administration
for a long time about shovel-ready jobs
and green energy deals a lot of that
went into the Recovery Act that was
passed in February of 2009 and when you
pulled back the curtain a lot of people
didn't like what was behind it are we
going to find a lot of that or some of
that in this Larry I don't think so I
mean there are no shovel-ready jobs
there is no green new deal this is aimed
directly I mean it's targeted directly
bill at individuals at families at small
businesses that's the key point here it
is targeted directly at them either
through direct assistance or tax
incentives or both and let's not forget
the Federal Reserve piece because that
cushions
the entire economy and stabilizes the
financial markets we're seeing better
trading as you noted in the stock market
that's a good sign there are credit
market issues but look we are helping
everybody I mean don't forget you've got
deferred income tax payments that's a
new wrinkle on this kind of story for at
least three months you've got deferred
payments on interest in principal for
student loans you know that's been a
burden and it the youngsters aren't
working we want to help them out in fact
you generally say this generally
speaking if you're not working either
because you're sick or because you get
laid off this is not a function of the
economy per se this is a function of
this massive external problem called the
corona virus and this is also temporary
relief I want to emphasize that we
believe and I hope prayerfully this
comes true we believe we're talking
about weeks and months not years okay
big difference 45 seconds lightning
round to you what's the jobs number
tomorrow look like do you think it's
gonna be a very large increase in in the
weekly on employ is it millions or what
what is it Larry I'm not at liberty to
say that will come out at 8:30 a.m.
tomorrow but it's going to be a very big
increase everybody in the market knows
that okay will the House pass this
that's on the table right now yes or no
Lee hot I believe yes it will yes the
house will they're on board thank you
sir we'll check in the last week where
we in a week bill hemmer in one week put
this package together with the help of
the Congress that's a good thing seems
to me to help Americans get through this
thank you Sarah we'll talk soon Larry
Cohen thank you